what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
attack on titan
a lot of you enjoyed my video where i
ranked all the titan shifters from
weakest to strongest so i thought it
would be cool
now that the series is over to look at
all of the information about all of the
jaw titans and rank them for weakest the
strongest the jaw titan power
specifically is definitely one of my
favorites
and the final version we saw of it is
insanely hype
and i'm super excited to talk about it
if you want to keep these attack on time
videos coming then make sure to give
that like button
a colossal smash until it's blue and let
me know what titan power you would like
me to cover next in the comments
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next one to
drop you can always check out my growing
attack on time playlist where i got
videos about all-time shifters all
acronyms and much more
before we get into it a big thank you to
darkfire heroes for sponsoring this
video
darkfire heroes is a new rpg that is
changing the rpg landscape collect
common rare and epic heroes upgrade them
and lead them into battles in a massive
campaign full of exciting levels and
challenging bosses
since they only just launched this is
the best time to start playing darkfire
heroes and if you do you will receive a
special limited edition daily bonus for
your first seven days
just click on the special download link
down in the description and start
playing for
free battle your way through armies of
deadly monsters and ghouls
and earn incredible rewards in this
non-stop real-time strategy game
and just wait until you see their unique
pvp modes darkfire heroes
actually has multiple exciting ways to
play pvp including castle conquest where
you battle in real time to destroy your
opponent's castle before they destroy
yours
and hero race where you race through a
stream of enemies to see who can reach
the end of the level first
both pvp arenas offer amazing daily
rewards and exciting new ways to try out
different team combinations
download darkfire heroes for free by
clicking the top link in the description
and take advantage of the limited
edition
bonus while you still can it's free it's
a lot of fun and it supports this
channel so check it out link in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it manga spoilers and
all first up we got emir of the survey
core
she was skilled enough to get top 10 in
her class but she purposely allowed
historia
to get in 10th place so historia would
have the safer option to join the
military police
if she so chose considering the fact
that first place was an ackerman
and second through to fifth place were
all titan shifters
emir may well have been able to get in
the top six
if she actually wanted to according to a
data book emir got 7 out of 10 in combat
10 in initiative
7 in wits 2 in teamwork and a 10 in
pickiness
after she ate marcel galliard she gained
the ability to turn into her version of
the jaw titan which was also known as
the dancing titan
her 5 meter titan had a very different
look compared to marcel and galliard's
draw titans
notably she lacked any hardening around
her face and claws
nevertheless she possessed the jaw
titan's characteristically strong jaws
claws and its great swiftness
compared to the other nine-time powers
her smaller chimpanzee-like body
gave her the clear advantage in forest
areas in which she could maneuver
as well as tarzan himself at utgard
castle she was able to take out some
pure titans by biting through their
napes but she couldn't hold back so many
much bigger titans for long and had to
be rescued by mikasa in the rest of the
reinforcements
notably she was trying to help hystoria
and the others but if her goal was
simply to escape
it shouldn't have been a problem for her
swift titan the way the dancing titan
quickly scaled and moved around the
tower would not have been possible for
the other eight titan powers
interestingly enough emir's titan was
able to speak
unlike the other jaw titans but her
titan couldn't speak as well as zeeks or
peaks titans
so overall emir's version of the jaw
titan was not weak it had the usual
strengths you'd expect from the jaws but
as we'll see
she ranked this slow because the others
were even more impressive
next up we have marcel galliard the
brother of porco the saver of reiner and
the food of emir
marcel was chosen over his brother to
become the jaw
titan so you could totally make the
argument that he should be higher on
this list than
porco but i feel like we just haven't
seen enough of his titan in action to
warrant putting him ahead of porco
still it should be noted that he most
likely did have the potential to be a
stronger draw titan than his brother if
he survived and gained more experience
with his titan powers in the warrior
program you could see that marcel was
often leading the pack
and in runs came ahead of both his
brother and reiner
in fact marcel was singled out among the
warrior candidates for being especially
strong
and quick-witted both of which are very
desirable traits for titan shifters
as marcel's jaw titan was destroying
cannons with his claws
and crushing them in his jaws the
military described the jawtine as
follows and i quote the jaw titan is an
assault unit
its small size makes it the swiftest of
all its powerful claws and jaws can
crush just about anything
end quote like his brother and unlike
emir marcel had a noticeably hardened
face and claws that would increase his
defense and the destructive power of his
attacks as well
since later mikasa would notice how
porco's draw time was way faster than
amir's version
it's likely that marcel's version was
faster than amir's as well
since he was even faster in his human
form than porco
obviously we don't know to what extent
human abilities translate to the titan
but it would make sense that they did
especially since the warriors are made
to undergo
such harsh training again you could
totally make the argument that marcel
should be placed above porco but since
he died so
soon after inheriting the power and
since we saw way more
things from porco's draw titan i had to
personally place marcel's version here
next we have you guessed it porco's
version of the jaw titan
even though his brother was more skilled
than him in the past we must keep in
mind that porco was more trained and
experienced
during his fight against aaron and
mikasa than he was as a kid
he also seems to have had much more
experience using the jaw
titan than marcel did and we know that
titan experience is an important thing
since grisha's attack titan defeated
frida's founding titan
even though the founding titan should be
the strongest and that was in part
because she was inexperienced with the
power
we first see porco's draw titan during
the battle of fort slava he cruises
through the battlefield uprooting rail
tracks
with his jaws protecting gabby and falco
with his face armor
crushing anti-titan cannons with his
hardened claws that were about to hit
reiner and so on he
jumps quickly to avoid anti-titan shots
himself and the air time he gets is
truly impressive
walls are nothing to this agile titan
porco's draw titan was arguably the most
impressive titan
in the battle of fort slava now let's
jump to aaron's attack on marley
where porco's draw titan impressed me
even more initially as
aaron has the warhammer titan crystal in
his titan hand
porco's draw titan comes in quick and is
about to straight up take the founder
back from aaron
before levi comes in and slashes his jaw
so that he can't bite
if it wasn't for levi aaron would have
been history here thanks to porco's
titan speed and technique
next time they face off during the same
fight porko is able to catch one of
aaron's punches in his jaws and he
slashes away at him insanely quickly
with no mercy aaron is forced to use the
tiber crystal in order to block the
attack and that's when he sees that
porco
can even damage these seemingly
indestructible titan crystals this was
insane when i first saw it and it
suggests that those claws and jaws can
truly break through
anything and if that unprecedented
slashing strength wasn't enough
it is at this point that mikasa comments
on how porco is fast
and that it's totally different from
when amir had the jaws
they are truly impressed by the power of
the jaw titan in porcus control
the first time it was levi and this time
mikasa ends up saving aaron by slashing
the jot titan's legs
aaron then proceeds to use porco as a
nutcracker in order to steal the
warhammer titan power
but that rather embarrassing and kind of
hilarious nutcracker situation aside
porco truly blew my mind in this battle
and made me re-evaluate the strength of
the jaw titan in general
if it wasn't for the ackerman's helping
him it didn't look like aaron could have
escaped the jaws and claws of porco's
titan
when the warriors attack parody porco is
no longer a match for aaron's titan
which now includes the powers of the
warhammer
the countless spikes sprouting from
everywhere and hardened karate chops are
too much for porco's jaw titan to handle
so after he gets mortally wounded he
ends up passing his power on to the
final
and believe it or not most impressive
jaw titan user
falco grice guys i cannot tell you
how much of a fan i am of falco's titan
before we knew what the night nighttime
power would be as a community we hoped
and theorized that it might be a flying
titan
and when the warhammer was revealed it
was epic and its powers
did not disappoint but we also thought
we might have to give up on the idea of
a flying titan
so when taco became a flying draw at
titan i was beyond
excited as an ldn warrior candidate
falco was already very fast
even able to beat gabby the star
candidate in a race
so it seems fitting that rather than
inheriting the armored titan as he
initially planned to he ends up
inheriting the swiftest titan power
because he was turned into a titan using
zeke's spinal fluid and powers
falco was actually able to take on
animal characteristics
in this case his jaw titan took on
bird-like characteristics which included
wings
his is the first and only flying titan
we see
and its significance should not be
overlooked the marlene military knew
that the future of warfare was gonna be
in the sky
and they wish they had a flying titan so
they could control the skies all the
better
falco's titan because it can fly is the
only one that can maneuver
around aaron's giant skeletal titan and
the rumbling effectively
falco's draw titan should have the same
ability as porcos to claw and bite
through
anything it also has a hardened beak for
additional defense against attacks
and i don't think i need to explain all
the benefits that being able to fly
would give one in battle
i'd also wager that falco's airborne
titan is faster than porcos for
fun let's take a look at the fastest
land animal and its speed compared to
the fastest bird and its speed
the fastest land animal the cheetah can
reach speeds between 68 miles per hour
and 75 miles per hour the fastest bird
and fastest member of the animal kingdom
the and i don't know if i'm saying this
right peregrine falcon
can reach speeds of 242 miles per hour
which is more than three times faster
than the cheetah and we're definitely
being asked to associate falco with a
speedy falcon
since his name is literally one letter
away from spelling out falcon
during chapter 136 we see his titan
speed up and dive towards aaron's titan
while avoiding countless projectiles
i have no doubt that this level of speed
would even put porco's speedy titan to
shame now imagine combining that diving
speed with the jaw time's powerful
slashes and bites
and you get the strongest jaw titan of
all
and that is it for this video all jaw
tines rank from weakest the strongest in
my view
let me know your thoughts and if you
would rank them differently in the
comments
if you do want to see this kind of video
for the other time shifter powers
like the founding titan let me know by
smashing that like button until it's
blue
and leaving a comment if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next video to drop out of the sky like
falco
feel free to check out my growing attack
on titan playlist which includes videos
about all the titan shifters
all the ackerman's and much more link to
that is in the description
thanks again to darkfire heroes for
sponsoring this video
download darkfire heroes for free by
clicking the top link in the description
and take advantage of the limited
edition bonus while you still can
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
my
you